I wanna marry go I wanna lose control so
I'm ready to roll
[Music]
like I've been walking
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy Thursday it's
almost Friday Friday gotta get down on
Friday we were just talking about how
kids pop released their new music video
for their their take on Liz O's truth
hurts and it's so crazy like those kids
are [ __ ] crazy it's why friends great
till they gotta be great
yep it's good stuff on it's not just
check the DNA test turns out I'm a
hundred percent that kid it's about a
friendship that went south and honest
relatable it's person into this
situation I can't leave you bring your
hair straight today didn't notice that
um yes I'm trying something new with my
hair it does it look really long yeah it
does but I also just like wanted to
serve up some professional glamour on
the show today I know with that quilted
cropped sweater Jack right it's tweed
season um for a number of reasons one
because I'm in the paper this morning
and they're calling me a host which you
know what I am and I'm gonna dress for
the job that I have hmm any job that you
want right - I'm in the paper this
morning so there might be some new
people here and they just wanted to show
them that we're a professional ship
morning show you know yes even if we go
off the rails sometimes like we're it
these jeans clean these jeans twenty
five thousand and three we actually have
something to do today where we have to
look nice so I was like I always go
through this where I'm like you know
what I'll wear something on the show and
then I'll change before no thing we have
to do but it's like why don't the
toasters get the best of me no totally
she got the best me she broke did you
see that video of all those drunk people
at Waffle House at 3:00 in the morning
and the music comes on and it's beer
never broke my arm and they're all like
begging that [ __ ] yeah where'd you see
it you know Twitter to see honestly that
was something I thought like for sure
margosa and you know what I started
following Luke combs updates on Twitter
and it's really improved my quality of
life um also maybe you didn't see the
video because you're in the masa your
head against the wall and forgot about
it yeah yes crazy
crazy times crazy crazy it's been a
really crazy week but now we're nearing
the end of the week and we're here to
give you a great chef and I was gonna be
home for my first weekend home in
forever I feel like I say that all the
time like low-key I'm home all the time
I need to like relax like I'm so busy
you know and I'm gonna Malibu this
weekend like no I'm Malibu Barbie yeah
that's very sheshe of you it's very so
fun
actually I don't know we've been to
Malibu I've never like spent time in
Malibu like not looking for Yolanda
Hadid so old house yeah I know and I
found another interesting factoid about
Robert Smith who's this billionaire who
we've been talking about he also just
bought Yolanda Hadid old house and marry
someone DM that to me but I don't know
if it's true just buy it no she was
renting it like she just took a
staycation somewhere yeah um that's
crazy
yes and another piece of information
that we didn't know about the college
that he spoke out that it was an
all-boys it's a HBCU historically black
college university and it's very
prestigious so oh well Rory just keeps
getting better yeah I know it's the best
story and honestly if Robert Smith's
daughters not a toast I'm really so
upset I'm gonna be upset too it's a
story that keeps on giving I hope
tomorrow you have a new update for I'll
let you know he's just and so many
people like work for him and his
companies and they've been damning me
let's think he's like such a great guy
why not like the birkin rumors totally
true and then the executives right
someone else will depend number can be
talked in Crocs or the Birkin wives
Scott Brad Birkett patient the executive
wives Scott Perkins but then like a one
level lower like the presidency suite
yeah they got Prada oh yeah gonna stamp
your lessees impression of me honey um
there needs to be show about the Birkin
Wives
yeah the wives of the exact set Robert
Smith's company Oh totally I would watch
you too
I would literally watch anything these
days because television is trash except
Real Housewives of Dallas which we will
recap at the end of the show it was
[ __ ] amazing it was it's slowly
turning into like one of the better
franchises a hundred percent I loved
having Stephanie home and on the show
yesterday oh yeah oh my god I took so
much just happened since then I
literally forgot she's the most
beautiful woman she's a precious gem of
a woman she I think had a good time I
think she did - I know is when my
favorite things about her like I think
she thought most
when we were talking about home in
lockers I totally agree and it's like
that's how much she like rides for her
husband yeah that she's like excited to
give him so much shine when it's like
always about her be a beulas no I
couldn't agree more and then before the
show started she was like telling us how
excited she was because she listens to
the toast I'm like oh my god Stephanie
home in P John herself is a toaster PGM
rehad like I can't I can't she has so
many acronyms pyjama Rahad everything
everything and then we also have Abigail
Baker on the toast at the end of this
episode no Baker her name is Abigail
Hawke what she plays Abigail Baker it's
gonna be using and she is here to
promote Blue Bloods at a new show she's
working on so I'm some of the parking
excited to talk to her like I was
reading the comments of the questions we
got for her on Instagram like getting
more excited me too and that means they
had actually really good question yeah
and I'm excited here and she's like yes
I talked to Tom Selleck like almost
every day every single one of her scenes
talk on sound right okay she works for
him yes and Gormley like the design gift
Sarge
yeah gift Birkins we'll see we'll see
we'll see um so what I believe I think
it's time cuz we actually have some good
stories okay some piggybacking off of
previous stories and it's gonna be good
stuff so without further ado here are
the past five stories that you need to
know before you wake up and take a bite
out of your morning toast and it's time
and I'm gonna let you do what you gotta
do but in the words of you know my dear
friend Kanye West imma let you finish
but I would be deeply heartbroken remiss
and devastated oh if I didn't let you
guys know that today's episode is
brought to you by the farmers dawg
so I have a dog and he is hungry all the
time and for a long time us being in
kibble just because like that's what
they sell in the store and like I watch
TV and like all the dogs eat kibble
but at the end of the day if you think
about it kibble is like the fast food of
dog food it's like really not that good
it's not made from fresh ingredients so
that's why we love the farmers dog
because if you have ever wondered who
ever wondered like why every dog food no
matter how pretty the bag is or the
brand or the price is dry smelly and
burnt out palates why do you why do we
feed this stuff to our beloved pets
literally my son for every meal of their
life well now we don't have to thanks to
the farmers dog the farmers dog makes it
easy to feed your dog real fresh food
actual food you can see smell and taste
if you really want to they deliver it
right to our house exactly when we need
it we just reach into the fridge open
and pour they're real us
fresh vegetables I love the turkey
recipe with carrots and spinach and
there's no wondering what's in our dog
stood because we actually see the
ingredients every time we serve it
they're farmers dog has worked with top
vets to make their food complete and
balanced for your dog so you know
they're getting the nutrition they need
to thrive and it's pre-portioned for
them so you don't have to worry about
under Earl burr feeding because for the
longest time I was severely over feeding
Theo and when my dad came over she's
like how much are you feeding him and
I'm like a cup per meal and she's like a
cup reveal my 600 pound Rottweiler eats
that I'm like oh okay thanks so now he's
on a third of a cup but like it's really
hard to know well I'm not a doctor it's
hard to know what the right portion is
so with plans starting at just three
dollars a day less than a morning coffee
these days I'm able to make it work for
our family and we have peace of mind
knowing that Theo is making a long-term
investment in his health
the farmers dog is the smarter healthier
pet food making it as simple as possible
to give your dog a better diet start
your child today go to the farmer's dog
calm slash toast and you'll say 50% and
get free shipping that's the farmers dog
calm slash toast for 50% off your trial
with free shipping the farmers dog.com
slash toasts sign on look like Theodore
for Chairman everyone wishes they could
be CEO every one week I wish I could be
CEO just getting stroke all the girls
want to pay him all the guys want to
[ __ ] him yep
it's good stuff okay also really quickly
while we're just like promoting stuff I
do the pay trottibus owed with tellers
check retailers checker was literally at
my house four or five hours I'm like I
didn't want her to leave like she we did
a podcast episode for her podcast case
of Taylor which I think is coming out
this week and then she we did a patreon
where we took questions from the patreon
members and it was just like the best
episode she is so open about everything
it's like when I first met her years ago
she was married to a man and then she
was dating this girl and like her
background was so interesting and she
had really was having trouble like
identifying herself because she'd never
thought she was gay but she like fell in
love with her best friend so she's like
no I'm not gay like if Taylor died like
I would go back stating that oh my god
and now like so many years later we were
talking about like how she labels
herself and she really labels herself
bisexual now would you just hope so
interesting like the arc of how she like
came into who she was yes is such an
interesting person it's a write-ups I'm
so excited to listen and she's [ __ ]
hilarious and she's only person louder
and talks faster than me know she's such
a pro and she's interesting it's hard to
get to a girl who des Beaux we didn't
even prep we just like how we do it for
most people I'm like I talked them
she just sat down she we recorded for
like three hours and we could have gone
more I really love her oh my god that's
amazing okay well first story it's some
sad news because Kylie Jenner has been
hospitable hospitalized for a severe
illness she is very hospitable just
asteroid woods shots mother [ __ ]
fired
Kylie Jenner is what happened oh my god
a fly no I just over exerted so much
like a piece of food came flying out my
throat Wow piece of rice that's Kim oh
that's on branch yeah
Kylie Jenner is suffering and has been
for several days with an intense illness
that required her to check into a
hospital this week TMZ has learned
sources familiar with the situation tell
us Kylie was admitted to an LA area
hospital one source described it as a
severe flu-like symptoms which included
nausea and dizziness
so then Kylie took to her Instagram and
posted hi guys so as as you know I was
getting ready to go to Paris for the
bomb math show at Paris Fashion Week for
the launch of my makeup collab with
Olivier which by the way the coolest so
it's awesome it's not for me first it's
personally cuz it's like I don't go with
such you know crazy colors but it's like
something I wanna hang on my wall you
didn't know by the way like it's our
Kylie in the collabs like this is so
[ __ ] prestigious this is prestigious
it's in tune it's everything she said
unfortunately I'm really sick and unable
to travel I'm heartbroken to be missing
the show but I know that my amazing team
and my friends weren't in town for the
event will help me be there in spirit
creating this collection with Olivier
has been a dream of course this
collection isn't just for runway I
created this so that you can have a
piece of this once-in-a-lifetime event
I'm so proud of this collection and of
Olivier and our friendship vision and
creativity really comes across and the
products we created for you guys make
sure you guys watch the show with me on
Friday it's going to be an epic event
and I can't wait I Love You Olivier
congratulations and I'm sending you all
of my love this just sucks like Kylie
does nothing like she stays in her house
all [ __ ] day she goes to like three
events a year and like this is an
important one because she has a club and
because it's cool it's Paris Fashion
Week and homegirl get sick yeah like she
doesn't do nothing she works from home
you know what I mean leave Calabasas
usually yeah her office is in Calabasas
the once in a few times that she has to
she's been chucked out down by an
illness but I think the show is still
gonna be great and be so cool if she was
there but
I'm really excited for this show and I
think like her getting sick and now
promoting the show is giving her for the
brand baby yeah it's like gearing a
blonde excitement like I was excited for
the cloud but I didn't know there was a
fashion show and right so like oh well
now I'm excited where can i stream it
and you saw that her assistant Victoria
and Stas did like the unboxing because
they're in Paris I guess they were
waiting for her but she didn't end up
coming they did the unboxing they swatch
it was just as good as Kylie's anyone
who's actually hilarious they're like
please apologize for our swatches like
we that's so funny because people get
really upset that bad swatches yeah like
you can't like you need to have like
hairy arms like I had moles and hair on
my arm like I would be the worst [ __ ]
swatch er yeah I'm so vascular like
there's so many freckles yeah oh yeah no
if I did I would need to get like an arm
wax and also facetune well I feel like
she probably does her own swatches on
Victoria because like when they're home
so maybe just hold a phone swatch and
use your arm like you need at least
three hands maybe four yeah no I think
you need to someone to hold the phone
and someone to swatch Victoria anybody
hands I mean not three sets of heads
like the actual hands yes yes agreed
also speaking of swatches did you see
the trailer for the jeffree star
documentary I did what are your thoughts
I mean I'm looking forward to it
actually didn't watch the first one that
people loved and I think Geoffrey star
was like this really like controversial
polarizing figure but the first talking
about her like really humanized him and
I think was really helpful in like
launching his career even further so I
think it's great they're doing another
one
I feel so conflicted about Geoffrey
Stark aside I am and I don't know what
he calls his fans like I am one of them
like every time he releases a new video
I watch it like my YouTube app has
recently become like my favorite thing
and I just think he does such
interesting hauls like he did an entire
one of Dollar General makeup like they
have their own brand it was actually
pretty good but when it came to that
whole tachi drama like I really was not
on his side yes so I just I'm feeling
like you know I conflicted Stan I
understand and I'm in the morning tube
the morning show starts YouTube group
and it's just like they are a wealth of
knowledge there's so much history today
Jeffrey star has been a just join the
morning too he's been on the internet
since myspace she started out as a
singer like there's so much there that I
don't even know we need him on the show
yeah Jeffrey star yeah feel like hey I
think he's never in New York yeah I
think he doesn't leave his house no he
doesn't leave his house because it's
[ __ ] enormous and he also died was a
[ __ ] enormous house in Grand
Michigan which is where his boyfriend's
project oh you ever end up watching his
pink balls and of course his closet I
was literally choking it was cranny
Jackie you should watch his videos
because I've watched a lot of his videos
and then the last video i watched was
the Kylie skin video I know that way
it's disappointing Shane and yet the
documentary and it was disappointing and
that was like I was very much in the
YouTube drama for a minute with James
and Tati and I just wanted to get to
know all the players and after that
video I was like this is too upsetting
you know that one was really upsetting
but that and that's what I mean when
it's like it's conflicting especially in
YouTube like being a Stan if someone is
so hard because there's so much drama
like everyone is like on bed and Jeffrey
star-like is so anti Kylie and it's so
annoying and like I just watched a video
he did it was me MARTA watching was 40
minutes he reviewed Lady Gaga's house
laboratories and it's literally four
products it's like an eyeliner and like
some lip glosses and eye shadows like
it's not a full makeup line which was
the consensus well he like liked it and
it was just like I can't imagine that
it's that much better or worse than
tight Kylie's it's like he goes after
Kylie's because I think it like makes
him feel cool and I don't think it's a
real gripe with Kylie's products and
that's what makes me upset but I still
really like him but like there are parts
of his business that I don't like what
bothered me about the Kylie skin video
wasn't anything that Jeffrey did it was
actually the same Shane was really
annoying me like Jeffrey was using
everything giving pros and cons and
that's like a very good it was like it's
in my mouth like you did 500 points of
the foamy [ __ ] baseball in your mouth
because you put it in your mouth yeah so
then it tastes that yeah it's a [ __ ]
face wash um yeah I don't know if I'm
gonna watch this documentary I couldn't
get through the whole trailer even but I
also don't know that it's for me because
I'm not like so but they also cover they
were filming the dining area during the
James Tati J Jeffery drama so that part
might be really interesting but it also
feels like the documentaries a lot about
Shane yeah you know I don't I'm not
ashamed Stan like I like the this stuff
he makes but I watched something he did
with Jake Paul and I was literally he's
at his house talking so much before Jake
Paul even got there and he skipped right
through it like to me he's not the star
he's the filmmaker yeah okay
well it'll be interesting and yeah be
cool when it comes out okay were
thinking of Kiley wishing her the best
hopefully she gets well soon
and I hope everything is okay and I hope
it's not contagious yeah but I also
sometimes when
like our sick you never know what is
actually going on so I just hope that
everything is asaji yeah next story in a
case of the morning toast called it Brad
Pitt is not dating sat Hari Khalsa
despite report duh despite reports the
actor is not dating spiritual healer and
jewelry designer saath Hari Khalsa
rather a source tells a news any rumor
of romance between the two is quote
entirely false and coming from Satara
cosa herself or Brad Pitt trying to make
Kourtney Kardashian jealous uncleared
yeah like honestly this is a sprinkle of
Kris Jenner in it because this article
ran on a news and you know that's kris
Jenner's go to platform also TMZ nobody
the original one was us you notice so I
sweetly wrote it and then Brad has been
hanging out with the janitors okay Chris
can you help me with this thing I feel
like Brad Pitt like probably doesn't
have a publicist like he's actually some
people are literally too famous for our
publicist yeah so I think you probably
texted Chris was like yo can you handle
this in she was like I got you boo yeah
a hundred see I could see the whole
interaction like happening right rather
pit and Khalsa are simply friends a
point they proved while celebrating his
new film ad astra last week at the
flicks after-party quote she was with
another girlfriend and was talking to
Brad a second inside that shared with me
but at no point during the party did
there appear to be an obvious PDA or any
indication that they were romantic Brad
didn't really talk to her much he was
talking to different groups of people
it was just friendly and not romantic as
the morning toast speculated yesterday
Brad Pitt can not be tamed and I'm sorry
I don't think it spiritual healer is the
girls do it I think it's Khloe
Kardashian I think I well I know what
you're saying and I want I want to agree
with you I think I have to be realistic
and I'm throwing my hat in with Courtney
yeah no but we said yesterday Courtney
is the obvious match but Khloe is more
of a personality like I think they can
be a better compatibility factor I don't
know but also how you think about both
would be Jim and I just I'm not gonna
get off of this train unless like Brad
Pitt is in the middle of the street
making out with a woman that is not
either of them you know I will not
believe and you're not filming a movie
until there's you know what they say no
ring nothing this until Brad Pitt is
married to someone else he in my mind is
a Kardashian in the
yeah maybe he's dating both of them Brad
kardashian-jenner rug tenor sounds like
a no Chris caitlyn jenner's sons he
should date Chris Brad Jenner sounds
like he could be one of Caitlyn Jenner's
sons Brody Burt Brandon Brad love it
love it
okay next story is just an interesting
one
wait also before you jump in we never
spoke about how I started watching the
hills oh my god
putting this down yeah I just wanted to
talk about it really quickly because I'm
not I'm only like five episodes in and
there's so much to unpack first is that
Mischa Barton of it all she's literally
my fave I only want good things for her
like she's really seems like she has her
head on on straight and if you listen to
the media in the past couple of years
you would think she was like crazy like
member there was that video of her like
yelling at a wall in New York yeah
offense then like you would think she
was so crazy but she seems tougher
head-on really straight like really like
a loves the art of acting and and I
think the hills is gonna be really good
for her and I love her and I just like I
want to protect her agreed agreed
I'm so glad I knew you would feel that
way yeah are you enjoying it overall was
it a good recommendation it's a good
recommendation just because like the
cultural implications of the show are so
interesting like this actually is like a
cool group of young Hollywood that
connect but it's not like the best show
ever
no but it's it's full of interesting
factoids right like that kid Brandon Lee
I was like who the hell is this kid and
then his mom walks in and she's Pamela
Anderson I was like holy [ __ ]
yeah so that was just interesting and
he's definitely has had a super
interesting childhood like growing up in
the fast lane and he also he's the
youngest one he's like but he's one of
the wiser ones yep he has his head on
straight and he's just a good character
on the show because he has a good
personality yeah I did not like the girl
he was dating oh but I just got to the
place where they're like shopping at
Fred Segal waiting for the phones again
you are going to die well it's my go to
plane show cuz it's on my iPad so I'm
what I'm Alan I'll probably finish it I
just need to spoil one thing no please
please please please okay but it's like
so funny fine I won't we'll talk about
it next week when I finish it where are
their thoughts Audrina Justin so when
Audrina and Justin first started to
connect him like oh my god this is like
kind of cute reminiscent like this in
mid 10 like I was really like feeling it
and after seeing them hanging out for
like one moment I would hated them both
so equally like I actually think I hate
Justin
more um have you met Justin's new
girlfriend yet no I didn't know he
hadn't I tell you about her I know I
have it and I showed you her Instagram
but no I have it
oh yeah breasts but no I have it um he's
just like so weird and like loose and
it's like okay that was cool when you
were like actually famous on the hills
like no younger you're on a reboot now
everyone's kids like get your [ __ ]
[ __ ] together and let's stop playing
games with five people but sorry Audrina
is just like such a pushover like
doormat like I can't even relate to her
on any remote level she gets better okay
love Brody and love that he's being so
open about the Kaitlyn of it all like is
she gonna come on no she's on the show
Caitlyn Jenner oh I'm sorry no no yeah
there's a lot there um and if you look
you can see things really confusing and
I love Caitlyn Carter she's so cute
their house is so cute like when he was
in the bathroom the window was open and
he was like throwing balls to the dogs
like je Malibu lighten change um and
obviously watching it now it's like sad
because I know that they're not together
um and I just can't see why and I feel
like she had a hard time cuz I only like
four episodes in I feel like she wasn't
open at first to the show like I think
that she gets more open like I think she
was kind of reserved she never did a
reality show before like all these
people are veterans so um she's a little
shy now but I like her a lot and I don't
like people coming for their
relationship but obviously now when they
justify yeah
which is really upsetting because I
think that they had like a nice thing
going for a moment except like him
sleeping in the car whatever and then
who else is on the show oh and we have
to talk about Perez showing up with like
his temper tantrum and then storming off
when we show Barton confronts him which
is probably one of the scariest thing
she's like confronting your bully like I
can't even imagine she's so brave she's
so brave I would have had such a hitman
I would have been my voice trembling I
wouldn't have known what words to get
out and not only did she like she said
her piece but she then stood her ground
shut him down and shut him down and then
he proved his true colors when he just
went off the handle and stormed out
stormy Webster it was so interesting
it was so interesting Oh gunner Pratt
has an assistant which is hilarious I'm
assuming that just means daddy it's just
they're all in such interesting places
in their life but II using about Jason
Wahler and Beau I love love love him
love his wife love his sobriety love
everything they have going on I want
only good things for them like I don't
want the show to make them crazy like
they have such a good life love his wife
like she's so on the straight and narrow
okay after this weekend you'll probably
be done with the show from your flight
yes so I'll talk to you about it that
guy's so and then you should watch Jason
Wahler unjustice if we trust him
Sylvester oh okay good good it's just
full of I get him his name and Jessen
Bobby's name confused because like they
played the same role like bad boy yeah
yeah bad bad boy shiny toy with the
price you know that I've bought it you
know but you can either change or you
cannot yeah look that's what it's a two
row two roads diverged in a yellow wood
that's one of them is chase it and one
of them is Justin Bobby
that's what Robert Frost was referring
to and Justin Bobby took the road less
traveled 100% okay
speaking of reality stars Cassie
Randolph sets the record straight on her
relationship with Colton
okay so Cassie Randolph took to
Instagram and said that she was gonna
speak on some rumors that were
circulated and nobody really actually
heard I heard the rumor I saw it it was
a reddit screenshot I'm in snatchler
nation so that's where the tea is and it
like said that you know they're
struggling and what what else did it say
amazing that it said was that no
relationship is easy her family hates
him yeah oh that's what the thread
thread said and I'm pretty sure she said
it was an art there was an article maybe
an articles coming out about them but it
was just a reddit thread and I
personally if I were her I wouldn't have
liked address it on her Instagram or 1.7
million people are more people are
talking about something not a lot of
people were ever really talking yeah and
now they're probably like what's the
drama yeah but so she she felt the need
she took to Instagram and just wrote
about how you know there's all this
stuff circulating about her and Colton
and mob their relationship is not
perfect at all like it is good and
people go you know through ups and downs
and blah blah blah as our resident
bachelor expert snatchler what are your
thoughts I don't know it's you know what
I mean like it's like Irene or Mille
like I isn't a crazy thing for them to
say I just wish they weren't so like
fake on Instagram then you know like
every caption is like cheesier than the
next yeah and so if that's how you
actually feel great but if there's a lot
like I did there's something so weird
about like taking a break from all the
lies on your Instagram to address the
truth you know like ya know taking to go
from one extreme to the other to go from
the best of your relationship on
Instagram to what people are saying on
read and like can't you just like post a
picture of you encoding me like you know
we thought this morning
yeah
today was a rough day but it just
reminds you you know like I don't know
however you feel yeah like you make a
cheesy caption a little bit more honest
yeah like you stole my hat I stole your
hat but you stole a hard look at am I
supposed to believe that's a real couple
no no they are a real couple and I think
if they're going through very normal
struggles then that makes me believe
they're even more of a real confident
person but I don't know there's just
something about there both of their
instagrams in particular that is so like
inauthentic and kind of cheesy that I
think people are even more quick to like
question them but that's a lot of
couples on Instagram are inauthentic and
cheesy
um I think some of the couples like
whose love I really believe in like
they're not and they're really open
about like okay so I like live for
skating homodyne show like elastic and
she's like always putting him on glass
like their look like real couple and
they also have cheesy captions like I
love you so much at which I'm sure they
do and then they also have like Michael
wouldn't shut up today like that's
[ __ ] wheel two percent they're
probably just trying to navigate how to
do cuz like they have gotten more
criticism that I think most people have
right so what they think by doing these
cheesy captions it's putting like the
haters like apathy but not so I think
that they're they've been I really do
think that they have been struggling
with the whole with all of it and it's
like they thought that they were doing a
good job
clearly not maybe the maybe now they'll
learn and maybe they'll be a little bit
more real idea to do the cheesy captions
yeah I didn't realize that it actually
was bothering me the cheesy captions
until all of this year now you're saying
because it's such a stark like
difference yeah and no one's asking for
it like no one needs it no you know what
they did they're not engaged like
they're just boyfriend/girlfriend and
she also was saying like she's known
couples that are dating for longer and
no one asked them when they're getting
engaged so like she's they're just
separately annoying yeah it's definitely
I think there's a lot of it that is
annoying but I think in general couples
on Instagram like we have to think there
has to just be some sort of like but
also it's worth mentioning like every
relationship is hard not just because
you're on The Bachelor is it hard like
two people compromising living together
like that is hard and it's never gonna
be easy but it's not hard because your
other option no but I do think that
being on The Bachelor going from me not
to being a nobody to so every person
where you're like everyone's capturing
your every move I think that's really
hard and I
you think that bachelor couples feel
pressured to make bad relationships work
because they don't want to clean another
base it's like they don't wanna have to
deal with like it's not just breaking up
it's like telling the world you're
breaking up like right and people have
they're so invested in these
relationships I think that that is a
heavy burden to carry
agreed oh great it's definitely harder
yeah it's harder it just adds a set of
problems but everyone has problems yeah
you know but then maybe you know it also
adds some pros where it's like okay we
got all these brand deals and now we're
we don't have as many money we have
problems as be mine right I was gonna
say like other people have problems like
real problems right yeah okay next story
is so cute for some reason I'm loving
this story and there's like an extra fun
factoid royal wedding alert Princess
Beatrice is engaged to Eduardo I know
the family motsi quote we are both so
excited I saw a picture they were like
Princess Beatrice is engaged I'm like
she already got married they look so
much alike her new Janee oh this is
serious yes I saw a picture I'm like
didn't we see a picture for walking down
a set of stairs in a wedding dress oh
yeah that's not even the fun fact so no
I know what's announced their engagement
on Instagram and I think that they got
engaged a little bit ago so now they're
just enjoying their engagement and their
engagement photos are beautiful and it
turns out that they were taken by her
sister yuju yuju niya ouch my idea like
I'm just like really loving that this
announcement like that's such a cute
picture it was definitely taken on an
iPhone maybe in portrait mode yeah and
they didn't have to like go through this
whole thing they were able to have like
a little bit of a private engagement
which i think is nice and I always like
feel for these sisters I feel like they
get all of the responsibilities of being
royal and none of the perks you know but
also I just think their image in the
media like especially when we were
growing up was so bad what was that
movie that was it was like a royal movie
um it's like what a girl wants yeah
there's like two cousins with the crazy
hats like they're always a movie
character yeah they're like casters yeah
they're like the student right so I like
feel bad for them when at the end of the
day I think they're like nice normal
girls 100% and like now they're ones
engaged ones married they're cute
sisters and they obviously like are
tight they're taking each other's
engagement photos and I'm just really
here for this story I just love a gaggle
of sisters you know and I love a royal
wedding I love a royal wedding and
there's this there's this cool because
it's royal and it's covered in the press
but it's not like so much pressure like
you want to cry yeah but don't you like
feel because there
always all this stuff with and I think
their dad is Prince Andrew right their
mom is Fergie I think they're not a shoe
central so they're going through it
right now and that's something that we
actually I keep reading about and I keep
saying like oh we haven't spoken back
out on the water oh my god I'm sorry
whatever you have seen connection
there's a big connection but you know
what I don't want to Mar her engagement
I agree with remembering this is the
connection together like there's so many
princes you know I was just like all
right Prince Andrew barely certain I
think you're right um anyways but I feel
as though they have the responsibilities
of being royal they have to be proper
their photograph they can't step out of
line but they don't get like the perks
of like I don't think they live in
castles you know they're not like the
the them know I think they do live in
castles no I don't think such a key if
that girl from what ladies in London has
a castle Earl of Sandwich no but that's
because she's an Earl
Jackie they 100% have a castle they
might not live there it might be like
their summer house that cuz they choose
to live in summer with their grandma at
Sandburg what's that place called
Sandwich know where she likes to go the
Queen in the crown I don't know you guys
know what I'm talking about I don't
watch the crown where she likes I can't
remember that I think I think they have
the best case scenario I think they get
a lot of it Kirk's I think they get a
lot of the perks of being royal you know
like the fame the money the royal
wedding but I think like they if they
you know pick their purse up off the
floor it's not gonna be in the Daily
Mail no I think they get like all of the
criticism in heat and none of the perks
which is just like I totally disagree
what they really don't get a lot of
criticism oh I feel like they're these
two no they in the Hat when they showed
up in the hats at one time and they
became like a media stereotype like that
sucks but for the most part like they
don't get paparazzi to everywhere they
go that's true and they're not like city
people consider that some people would
but like giant Princess Diana wouldn't
you know like that level like yeah they
don't have what Princess Diana had of
what now Harry and Wiliam are trying to
protect their wives from like they
really don't have that but they get
invited to all the cool events they
could probably you know go to Polo on
Sunday that's sure I feel like they're
in a great spot I feel like they're in a
great spot now you know growing up I
think was hard and also their mom was
like controversial they got divorced
which is like the craziest thing so I
think they were like kind of like a dark
spot like a [ __ ] stain for a little
while no but so I'm I don't know I'm
just I'm really happy for them and I'm
happy for this story and I love it
sister took the pics me a little
portrait mode action I love it it's so
cute so cute excited for the Royal and
they look so [ __ ] similar it's crazy
I didn't realize that they look so
similar let me look at the picture again
look you look similar boy sure one is
red hair you show me a picture like oh
my god
eugenie you thinks Eugenie Eugenie
Eugenie
you're just nyah - my idea oh maybe they
do look they look really similar but
they're not twins or sisters yes they're
sisters
okay fit and final story a little
business not so much business more like
a little business brought to you by one
of our favorite businesses tempered a
luxury fragrance subscription service
for perfumes and colognes a way for you
to discover new perfumes and colognes
without buying an entire bottle
more than 450 designer brands for you to
choose from on they got product Tom Ford
for such a Dolce yeah yeah Gucci Calvin
Klein you could choose a perfume you
want to try and they'll send you a
30-day supply that's 120 sprays enough
to apply more than four times daily for
a month if you're not sure what type of
scent you're looking for you can sort
and find your new fragrance by brand
style occasion season and more and then
new month you can get new fragrance new
month new you new fragrance same
fragrance replenish the travel size is
great because you can bring it on a
plane and with it an exclusive offer
just for our listeners you can get 50%
off your first month today at scent bird
dot-com slash toast that's only seven
dollars and fifty cents for your first
fragrance go to Sanford comm slash
choice and sign up for 50% off your
first month again that's scen tird comm
slash toast for you to try your first
perfume or cologne for just seven
dollars and fifty cents sign on smell
amazing oh the place where the Queen
goes is called Sandringham oh wait
thank you for reminding me I might meet
and greet in Vancouver I met someone
Margo named Sandrine from friends there
Ross and Rachel have a baby and they
cannot think of a name and that Rachel's
all like I actually spent on this
episode like last mode Rachel's very
like into like alternative you know
reign Sandrine Darwin and Ross is into
like Ruth and you know fairy
yeah like real like regular names and I
met a girl named Sandrine and I was like
Jewish friends and she was like yes like
does
everyone asked you like Sandrine Frank
she's like literally the first person
what I'm stop it's such a beautiful
maker really it is really a dream he's
like hi I'm Sandrine my kiln is made of
wheat I saw the episode where she takes
Courtney Cox's name yeah but then she
doesn't end up using it she doesn't use
yes yeah okay bit story it's not super
busy news but it's cultural news the
company that created you said fifth and
final story yeah before you said it
about the business is the business oh we
haven't said it yeah the company that
created Barbie is introducing a line of
gender-neutral doll I heard so Mattel
has come a long way since it introduced
the Barbie doll in 1959 on Wednesday the
toy company launched the line of
gender-neutral dolls called creatable
world where kids are invited to
customize their own doll that isn't
dictated by gender norms quote in our
world our dolls are as limitless as the
kids who play with them the company said
on its website
Mattel describes creatable world as a
doll line that is designed quote to keep
labels out and invite everyone in the
toy kit comes with short hair and long
hair options six pieces of clothing
three pairs of shoes and two accessories
that are both female presenting and male
presenting the dolls don't have the
curves of Barbie or the broad shoulders
of Ken oh so you really like non-binary
yeah interesting
great Mattel aside from that you know
major flub they hadn't the monopoly that
we spoke about a couple yeah go where
they were gonna have women making more
money than men they're usually on the
brink of like what's what it was Hasbro
okay okay this is this is great very
appropriate and Barbies have become
weirdly like a like a controversial
nakeds toy because it's like boys can't
play with Barbies like yes they had and
they've just become like almost and
there you know like tall skinny blonde
like it's not setting a great example
for kids but they've really evolved in a
mature and a pred responsible way i have
to give them credit I have to give them
credit to you they're always like trying
to evolved they have different types of
Barbies now when barbie can do anything
and i think this is a great photo
doesn't need a Ken Barbie doesn't mean
no Ken you anything this is a great step
for Barbies and kids everywhere yeah I
think this is the
really good yeah and dress it up however
you want yeah cuz Yves great no matter
where she goes dress her up from her
head to her toes members when there was
an announcement that they were making
life-size - and then life-size - came
out of no one watched it it was made for
TV and it was on free form and I believe
it was awful
yeah but like we didn't even watch it
but we were so excited because I was
excited for like a like Tyra Banks
Lindsay Lohan and like in a theatre yeah
but didn't know we thought we got late
for TV with Marshalls I should watch it
I feel like I don't like it you do run
terrible movies I love terrible movies
and I love Tyra I should have great
taste in terrible movies I do because I
can like some terrible movies are great
too and I'm gonna let you know which
ones a [ __ ] watch my favorite hallmark
movie yesterday called a feeling of home
yeah and she didn't love it as much as I
did but I think that's okay no I'm still
great I'm still a great home work though
sorry the greatest hallmark film to date
freshman father miss Christmas freshman
father manatee Chris based on a true
story real tearjerker a feeling of home
Real Housewives of Dallas recap oh my
god it's so good first of all I'm loving
this house in Korea it's [ __ ]
beautiful my unifo we need to go to cray
it's polo sheep I just I love these
women like I really do and I was having
a hard time last night because I know
that you like have really taken a liking
to Cameron and she's definitely like
loosened up and I was starting to take a
liking to her but then I was getting
flashbacks like she doesn't really get
participate in arguments but when she
does she's always wrong that argument
she had about buying a baby last season
was so stupid and she was so [ __ ]
wrong agreeing and I got so angry about
it and I was reminded of that feeling
because that conversation she was having
with Brandi she was so wrong and by the
way I have to say like Brandi has is
usually out of line like Cameron threw
the napkin first that's all I'll say
okay I completely agree she's a lot of
times wrong in arguments she was wrong
in this one for sure I'm gonna play
devil's advocate for one second because
I think Cameron struggles a lot with
being on the show she loves the perks
that come along with it and she
struggles with the fighting and the
drama and how people are gonna perceive
her because of her standing inside
because she just leaves so she just so
when she's in it like she just leaves
when someone's feelings are hurt because
of something that she said she asked
she can't see what they're saying she's
just seeing that she's being portrayed
in a way and like I don't think that's a
good quality for some time you can't go
on the show and only want the pros
another 100 cents but I do think that
she's working through it and like I do
see a lot of growth in her so while
she's not like my perfect favorite
character yet the fact that she's like
learning either there's you I do I I
look forward to seeing how she deals
with this continued issue with Brandee
today do you think she'll get it right
eventually but also in her defense
brandi is a tough person to argue with
like Brandi doesn't give a [ __ ] like she
has no one to answer to like her
husband's not gonna call her if she's
like she is her own woman and Cameron's
not like he has held to the standards of
her family of society so Brandis not an
easy person to fight with especially
when you're so conscious of like how
you're being perceived so I feel her on
that but like we say this all the time
there is value in just owning your [ __ ]
yeah on the house side she'll get there
yeah I do think that she will but right
now she's so filtered she is like five
different filters that everything that
comes out of her mouth has to go through
it's like her husband her mother in law
society and then she comes out with
something and it's like she's breaking
those down a little bit yeah but it's
taking her some time yeah and I just I
love her aesthetic so much and by the
way everyone is saying on this trip that
she's been so fun yeah and that she's
been so gratefully loosened up she was
talking about how many margaritas she
peed in the bush right so she's changing
I agree that's why I'm being really
patient with her because I went from a
place of like I never want to see this
woman on my TV gig and you're like oh
wow there's something really endearing
about her and watching her just mature
and and grow as a person
it's an interesting thing to watch I
agree I think she saw herself on TV and
immediately made some changes and like
we do with her we do get like the
society like hi Highland Park connection
license and that's a lot of what this
show needs everyone on a private chat to
her house in Colorado right we can't
forget so with that comes the filtering
and not understanding certain things but
I think she's gonna get to a place where
we're gonna we're gonna like the camera
that we see I actually really agree and
that's why it was just disappointing
because I feel like we made a little
progress and then I took a step back if
next week she doesn't still see what she
did like in another conversation with
Brandi if she's not like oh my god I
hurt you and I'm so sorry um I'll be
bummed disappointed but I think she's
just gonna take a little bit longer to
get
that activity days did in that huge bowl
was actually really cool like that bowl
is sick yeah yeah but that's interesting
Oh see I'm not like one for meditating
and stuff but it made me really want to
go to America you know by the by Miraval
I think even if you're not into like
health and wellness it's just like a
sick [ __ ] hotel no but like I can get
into it I feel me - I would definitely
go I thought what that Gina and uh
Bronwyn did when they walked through the
maze and like put their like things they
want to let go like I could totally do
that I could totally do that feels like
taking a giant [ __ ] no I usually think
that like things like that were like so
lame and like emo but I was actually on
the podcast talking to Taylor's trekker
about how she sounds like therapy is
like the most amazing thing like I'm
gonna do it I think about it yourself
like you've been one always this show
isn't long enough like all I want to do
is [ __ ] talk about myself like now I
can literally pay someone to listen okay
I think I wanna do it I just feel like
it juju a couples therapy a massive [ __ ]
at once a week yeah girl we just let
lightens al I totally agree he's five
fun what can you find one yeah a
therapist I want like a cool celebrity
therapist yeah who knows all the secrets
yeah okay that's not how it works ladies
no I know I know I think I mean honestly
after reading Howard Stern's about like
that's great that's what I said on the
podcast yeah because I was telling what
the jealousy thing that we spoke about
yesterday and she was like she like
hates Howard Stern because she was like
his number one fan and then he said to
her on the red carpet when she's working
serious
she gave really good bye gossip on
podcast and she really opened my eyes
and she's like so tough I thought she
was gonna be like you don't need therapy
she was like it's amazing I'm like oh it
is okay I'll do it
yeah buddy do it I mean people really
love it I think it's just depending on
who you are as a person I've tried it
before and it was it wasn't for me
really mhm
I'm gonna do it I think it'll be for me
I'm gonna give tonight live to talk
about my side I totally feel like I just
don't like to talk about my feelings but
it wasn't even that I actually was
really enjoying like I can unload all my
problems onto someone and they'll tell
me what to do right I'm ready for the
guidance but then it's not that they
just like want you to explore it more
they're not giving you answers they're
giving you tools yeah no that's not
that's not it okay back to four houses
of Dallas um that they addressed the
room thing because I did think LeAnn was
super rude about it and that's what I
said too um Stephanie yesterday but at
the same time like I want my own room
like I don't think that's unreasonable
yeah I should have gone about it better
I know and that always like bothers me
that whole like if he just went a bad
right but like it's true maybe if she
had got about better put than they might
have still been pissed that she wanted
to room alone and not with carry so I
don't have a horse in this race yeah
because I I would want my own room but
um did you think that 11 make a wish I
wish for lots of happiness for everyone
yeah that's a good one um what else
happened on the episode Oh Deandra was a
[ __ ] now she's honestly so funny and
the fact that she wouldn't go to sleep
was so relatable like you know you've
been around someone who's so drunken
like literally won't go to sleep and
just once like hang out and keep going
yeah yeah Margo Margo and your
bachelorette party actually you know
here's the problem you
you know what someone's like so drunk
and all they need to do is go to sleep
but like they won't go to sleep and like
everyone's going to sleep and they'll
stay up that was you want Jackie's
bachelor party back in black - always
you though this is what you always want
to go to slice is what you know you
always like talk all night about how the
nights they were gonna end and then for
us which just flips and then it's over
where it's like everyone else you know
if you're telling you the nights ever
gonna end okay I'm gonna keep drinking
ba ba ba but wouldn't that switch flips
for you but like now I'm really drunk I
can't go to bed but you're done you know
it's actually a great low burn of
getting to a point where now I need to
go that's that's the guy you're slowing
down you're just on or off I'm not a
winder you're not a winder no okay what
else happened
Dallas Polo was cute holo was cute short
APIs everything and grace just seems
like so difficult like getting to the
bathroom like the stairs like it just
seems like they're working hard yeah but
they're also drinking like they're
working and I couldn't believe they wore
the same outfits all day like they
didn't go home and change for dinner
that's so on housewife I know I was
actually thinking like what I would be
wearing there cuz you want to wear
something super cute too polo but then
it's also a treacherous day yeah
shorts in and it ain't time to change
and put Spanx on of them she made a
dangerous choice
yeah and it's one we almost make it one
place yeah she is being hilarious we've
never seen her this drunk I know the
show she and I wonder if she's like cool
about her if like she wakes up it's like
embarrass I'm sure she everyone wakes up
what I got moral hangover but she's
actually really fun drunk I think some
people who are like mean drunks or you
know right they they have people have
access to grind with them in the morning
like personally embarrassed that like
her Spanx were showing on TV but she
doesn't have to apologize to anyone yeah
that's a good place to be in um okay so
I think it's time I'm like a literally
so excited I'm like kind of nervous to
meet Abigail she was so sweet oh she was
okay we're gonna take a break go get a
snack go to the bathroom see Sally at
the water cooler or whatever it is that
you have to do well be back in five
minutes with a BL Hawk from Blue Bloods
we are taking questions from her that
you guys posted on our Instagram if you
have a question for her feel free to
head over to the morning shows Instagram
drop a comment on our latest post and
we'll do our best to get the question to
Abigail we will see you guys in a minute
bye
you
we are Sergeant herself you know where
is Abigail Baker
her name is also Abigail Hawk it is
having Hawk from Blue Bloods I just I
can't like this is the best day of my
life you are actually our second Blue
Bloods guest on this show because we had
Peter Herman oh man no he's not like a
staple he comes in and out you have been
there since day one area important areas
at the Barton high for blue blood is
married to a very important woman he's
she's so important did she come to set
everywhere said no I don't think she's
ever been to set MN but I've met her
twice so you know okay I'm living
vicariously through well that's so funny
cuz I just said I'm also a huge SVU fan
and I thought I had seen like pretty
much every episode but I was watching
reruns when me and Marga we're in
Vancouver and we watched an episode
where that you start in yes where your
son who was ill was kidnapped by your
husband who's a really really funny
episode what's that fun to film terrible
to film it was a gut wrenching I was so
dehydrated yeah crying I'm you know
literally every time Raoul and I did
that got wrenching scene which I won't
spoil it if you haven't seen it oh my
god I forgot about that part so crazy
obviously I'm gonna tell I'm gonna hurt
her kid it's like he's not gonna live
like he's super second baby he's he's a
vegetable
machines and she knows like the right
thing to do it was like take him and put
him out of his misery but she can't do
it so the DI blick literally unplug the
machine oh my god and they're like and
it was his last episode and it was also
like he didn't actually show and I'm
like did he just kill them like it was
so [ __ ] crazy it was actually such a
good I'm sorry I forgot all about that
part cuz I was just like so excited on
the kidnapping what did he try to like
even the Thursday were talking about
killing babies yeah well obviously not I
don't have coffee well did it not us not
us okay so you are obviously you've been
on Blue Bloods since since the episode
after the pilot wow that's so
interesting and it's just the dream job
right it's totally the dream job like
c'mon stand Dreamboats
yeah oh yes and you like exclusively
film with Tom Selleck I do well in
Gregory Jabara and Robert co-head Sarge
Gormley
occasionally Bridget Moynahan Grace's us
with yeah that's true
presently she's a bad mood she has to
come to one pp yes because it doesn't
mean she's gonna be butting heads with
Daddy Yeah right
you play his chief of staff yes
and you're also sergeant detective
detective sorry sorry it's all good I'm
sorry detective not forgiven did you do
and you know it's so funny
anytime I mean that like a New York City
police officer I'm like Jewish Blue
Bloods and a lot of them actually do
they do like they actually don't like
SVU they think it's like an unreal
depiction of their their career but
there's a lot of respect for Blue Bloods
I think so you know I think because it
really focuses on putting a human face
behind the badge you know it humanizes
this profession and it's I mean I get
recognized by police officers all the
time like I'm in a Penn Station oh yeah
I'm a Penn Station and they're like
Baker and they just watch me and I'm
trying to got my headphones in right oh
and my like baseball cap on and my
sunglasses of course now you all know
what uniform I wear what I always ask
because there's a like a genuine like
respect for the show because I think you
guys are a really good accurate job of
depicting the life of a family of police
officers absolutely and I mean listen at
the end of the day they want to go home
to their families right kids you know
their wives their sisters their brothers
and they are the community yeah I mean
that's that's what they are so and now
you're also in a new project called
distemper yeah when you play scientist
very different than a detective a very
very different so kind of similar and
it's premiering at the North Fork
festival it is that's exciting next week
right on Friday October 4 so tell me
what its what can I research you had to
do to be a scientist did a lot of
googling yeah wet MD super yes Web MD it
was very exciting
well there you know there really wasn't
a lot of information about her which
honestly made her more tantalizing to me
you know very very few pictures of her
her pictures all came like after she got
all of her accolades
after coming back from the Congo and the
Belgian government recognized her and
but she was the very first female
scientist to work for the Rockefeller
Institute
Wow and yeah so I just I read a book
that her partner Sarah Josephine Baker
wrote called fighting
life yeah I know molarity it's all about
the parallel you think yes and so that
that helped to kind of dive into that
time period and figure out what was
going on in New York was crazy in
nineteen eighteen twenty not as crazy as
it is now I mean I think there's some
scenarios but yeah New York is crazy
there's a lot happening you guys film in
New York right we do on the street yes I
don't intend
yeah to the set in Greenpoint Brooklyn
but we actually got a question for you
that I thought was a great question do
you think in any world in the next few
seasons like you will be played written
into a family dinner scene I have you
ever been at family dinner I have been
at the table but only in an official I'm
on the job capacity like when one pp has
not been functioning or you know
whatever the case is right if Frank's
got a death threat honestly you know
we'll meet at the Reagan House and how
headquarters be there so I have sat at
the table I think two or two or three
times but never I think everyone haven't
had a meal I haven't had any meals there
well me and Margo actually work we went
to visit right and we went to a family
dinner scene and us film in New York and
it was so interesting because there's so
many people at the table is the same ten
seconds we saw the same what's your new
year's resolution I remember like every
sister 100 times because all the angles
that the food and they have to keep
refilling the wine like it's very
interesting it seems like honestly would
be torture I mean I wouldn't know cuz
you know I don't gets it like I'd love
to be tortured and you have to have tons
of wine at top that warning it sounds
really terrible Isha's food that
honestly like our props Department is
phenomenal like those those meals are
and it's real food right it's real food
yeah it's real food and they have to
prepare for that many people at least
once a week right and like multiple
times but is if I met you two string
bean they literally have to replace it
right it's shitty Jackie was so crazy
Thanksgiving dinner you know 240 people
the food looks so good about yeah and
wonder if they finish their plates when
they're done yeah that's a good question
probably not I think they're so over
whatever meal they I don't know I mean
yeah I have
books at least there's some variety
right Bridget yes that was actually
really smart okay I want to take some
questions from Instagram we got so many
questions for you network guy claims
that you have an amazing singing voice
is that true what honestly my secrets
coming have you ever thought about
pursuing singing as a career or even
releasing an album of course yeah I mean
listen you know I've been I've been
singing since I was talking and my my
first foray into showbiz was a
production of The Sound of Music that I
did at a Community Church I'm Cheyenne
Georgia which is where I'm from
I was Gretel and prestigious yes Von
Trapp Family Singers
I think singing my whole life I mean
it's it's second nature to me I'm
certainly a you know a little bit rusty
and now I just have fun doing it on
Instagram and I singing with my tattoo
fellow cohorts Bob and Craig you know we
do some did some didn't sometimes I mean
Craig's a Tony winner so he's got a lot
more clout than I do
I'm talking about camp Seng so you're on
Blue Bloods so yes who really cares the
clap I know me are you guys crazy number
one question from Courtney M Brooks when
will season 9 be on Netflix no because
it's frustrating if you don't because
you know I had to PI CBS login all
actress all that stuff with like
directly so annoying so for a lot of
people it's becoming harder to [ __ ]
find Blue Bloods I mean listen all I can
say is just buy the DVD if you can't
wait yeah I hate saying that cuz I know
Netflix is so much cheaper you know and
it's so much easier like what's a DVD
player but I will say this if you're a
fan of Baker
there's an entire special feature
section featuring me on the DVD wow
that's so interesting you make a strong
case yeah you do so you know who cares
about Netflix because you can't see
those special features on Netflix yeah
that's actually very on the bloopers
Lindsay a doctor is have you seen
bloopers you know I always am watching
friends blooper reels cuz it's like so
interesting the best the best cousin
watch are do you think they're on
YouTube probably Oh Margo I'm sure
Tiffany your activity for us I'm Lindsay
a doctor credit what do you see Baker
doing in upcoming seasons do
any input in your character story not
really I wish that I could say that I
mean listen we all I think they are in
spot the writers are inspired by what we
bring to the table so in that respect
sure yes I have some input but I would
love to see some more information about
her husband who was spoiler alert shot
in season nine survived but I'd love to
see how that has changed the dynamic of
their relationship I know when Amy
Carlson's character Linda was shot she
comes back you know watching how that
that relationship developed between
Danny and Linda anytime they've had a
near-death experience obviously yes yes
now she's really dead she's not mostly
dead she's really dead we talked about
that because that was kind of weird and
I feel like there are two instances
where like I feel like there's casting
drama on Blue Bloods like when Jennifer
Esposito like randomly bounced which was
like the biggest mistake of her career
also divorcing Bradley Cooper wasn't a
good one but whatever and then we then
take room for Lady gaga
right right not too soon but then I was
gonna say then Lady gaga then Linda also
mysteriously disappeared like over a
season break I mean listen again I'm
over in one pp that's true I don't I
never get I don't get any of the like
drama like we're very drama-free over
there you know like where we just we're
really we have a great time yeah and we
laugh all the time and we cut up but we
never get any of the gossip like any
time I get to see Vanessa or Marisa on
set it's like the greatest day ever
because I hang out with a bunch of boys
all day and I get a female on set or if
we get a female guest star yeah oh man
that's a guy I mean I like I'm obsessed
with them you know where I Drive them
crazy
yeah oh we've had great guest stars but
like I was up Whoopi's but I did not
leave her alone all day I'm Tom Selleck
don't talk to me and give me some
estrogen please she nice she's amazing I
actually feel like she'd be the nicest
that she wears amazing socks and shoes
and shoes but like the socks are
incredible so listen back to Linda you
know
all I know is that it was a decision
that Amy made and I I just think she was
she was ready to move on and I loved Amy
Amy's an incredible mom and person and
an advocate for many charities and she's
lovely so all the interactions I had
with her were incredible I adore her and
I miss her I miss you Amy but I don't I
don't have any you know if you would
agree it was mean who wants to way from
the best job on television sorry you
know I I can't speak to that because I'm
not going anywhere
right so you film mostly scenes with
Gormley yes and what's the other guy's
name I forget more yeah DCPI and Tom
Selleck and obviously yes it seemed
intimidating he was actually really nice
to us he you know the the first day I
mean like I was this was 10 years ago
the first time I met him which is crazy
to say that yeah for 10 years and I just
remember I was so nervous to meet him
but he walked up and yes he's larger
than life I mean the guy's 6/4 he's a
living breathing walking on email
handsome so devastatingly handsome so
heartbreaking oh heartbreakingly
heart-stoppingly handsome - nice - but
he was so calming yeah like he just
immediately put me at ease and we we
established this report almost instantly
and he's wonderful
yeah he really know like I so he doesn't
intimidate me he's just a guy wanting to
do his job and do it right right and I
love that about him I've learned so much
from him yeah and if he takes his job
seriously
oh well it's important yeah I've got to
get it right and yes he is the police
commissioner of New York City so that's
a heavy heavy burden it really proud to
wear this is from Liz elder if you could
play another character in any other show
that you just like who would you play or
where would you want to be placed
oh my you know what what I can say this
here so there is there's a woman named
Kate brace trip okay who wrote a
wonderful book and of course now it's so
early and I haven't had enough coffee so
I'm going to hear if you need me okay
here it is
don't judge mom brain it's really it
came time it became quick
so she wrote this amazing book called
here if you need me it's a true story
based on her life and it was originally
like five six years ago optioned for a
pilot and then it it didn't end up you
know so many of them end up going yeah
to kind of employer cutting room floor
thank you that's the phrase I wanted but
she she's a warden and a chaplain with
the Maine State Police and she took up
her husband's cross he was killed in a
car accident and she raised her five
kids by herself and she became a warden
and a chaplain for him right so she took
on his career dreams and the way that
she talks about life and death and
motherhood and how she deals with
grieving people because Maine is you
know it's wildernesses racy I just I'm
so drawn to that kind of female energy
she's like a a warrior but she's quiet
Thunder and I i I just I'm putting it in
the universe that it's picked up ask
fully I want to see her I will be you
Kate brace drum that's so interesting I
never heard that story before
yeah maybe I should start mine hers but
you know I'll make a pizza Lorado okay
Melissa I always felt that Baker and
Jamie would get together at some point
during season one was that ever a
possibility I never thought that you've
always been married great I've always
been married we do you know we do have
ongoing jokes we'll and I that Jamie
will prank Baker like he'll call the
office and be like Baker the
refrigerator's running I love him so so
you know I think I think they they're
friends different real life yes you've
always been her not friends with
benefits right now were generated and
she's faithful and true that would be
like you know what so great about Blue
Bloods it's really like a family show
like you don't feel awkward watching it
with like literally anyone it's always
been like it always said it's like it's
to me it's so similar to SVU but like
with real personal storylines the
characters get the case like the murder
whatever but I find the Reagan's more
interesting than the cases like I could
live without you know SVU deals with
that's various views amazing questions
seasons but you're dealing with that
specific realm of detectives yeah as
opposed to the Reagan family which
you've got a DA you've got the police
commissioner
detective and you've got a sergeant Rao
you know so you see different facets of
the career yeah and I think that's why
it's so fascinating before I let you go
I just have like one technical question
for you when it comes to like you know
casting extras or like doing cameos like
where where do you stand on that like do
you have any power
I have no power at all is there like a
sign-up sheet yeah like on the bulletin
board or something yeah like if you know
anyone you know you can sign up in the
hallway there you can write in sharpie
yeah red sharpie and it recommends it
shows that I've been get I light it yes
and you can totally throw my name around
because it has tons of clouds I'm just
letting you know like I will definitely
be doing that and I'm gonna be I know I
will hope she said I could come here yep
Baker endorse her thank you having on
the show thank you for coming on this
show
hey let's premieres distemper - don't
forget - temper temper premiers of the
North Fork festival yes next week Friday
October 4th and then after that where
can people find it go to North Fork TV
for all the information and new season
of blue blood starts like smart all
right I'm gonna be able to watch alive
ok whatever
Rob's figure it out you think you so
much for being here Instagram at Abigail
Hawk with no e at the end no e at the
end just the bird you're not related to
yet no it's ad Li very sad no it's it's
a cry face thank you so much for being
here thank you guys for listening to the
morning toast millennium warning show we
go live Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m.
Eastern Time on YouTube feel free to
give this video a thumbs up like comment
subscribe you know what to do if you're
watching if you're available if you're
watching on podcast also available as
podcasts modify iTunes stitcher Public
Radio I Heart Radio all the places you
know thank you so much have a great day
we'll see you tomorrow cause it's Friday
I'm going some fast that's amazing
you